what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 update video as most of you know by
now this has been one of the most
exciting weeks for the Game of Thrones
community a few days ago HBO released
their first official trailer for Game of
Thrones season 7 and as we get closer
and closer to the premiere date HBO
continues to increase the promotion for
their number one series yesterday
Entertainment Weekly released even more
photos and this time they featured the
members of House Stark exclusively the
stark reunion hype and tease has
officially begun my friends but besides
all of us House Stark fans wanting to
see the family get back together during
season 7 that isn't the only interesting
thing about this photo shoot if you've
seen these photos released by
Entertainment Weekly that I'm sure you
noticed Arya carrying around some extra
steel in our head and if you look
closely you can see that Arya Stark now
has the Valyrian steel dagger that was
heavily featured during season 1 and if
you've only watched the series once or
you haven't read the books and you may
not quite remember this blade
this was the dagger that was used during
an assassination attempt on bran Stark
all the way back in season 1 episode 2
this was the Valyrian steel dagger that
led to the eventual arrest and first
trial by combat for Tyrion Lannister but
you may be wondering to yourself how the
hell did Arya Stark end up in possession
of this Valyrian steel because thus far
we've only seen her carry around needle
which is the castle-forged steel that
Jon Snow gave to her as a parting gift
when he left for the wall and the
television show the last time we saw
this dagger it was in Ned Stark's office
in King's Landing
raper Ned Stark was arrested and thrown
into a Cell Littlefinger came to his
office where he was attempting to get
Ned Stark to go along with his plan to
remove Joffrey from the Iron Throne
during this scene Littlefinger actually
puts his hand on the blade and later in
the same episode Littlefinger puts a
blade that Ned Stark's throat which then
Cersei and Joffrey has him arrested
which would eventually lead to his
execution this was the last time we
actually saw this Valyrian steel dagger
in the television show so yesterday when
these photos were released I was
discussing them with gray area and for
those of you that aren't familiar with
her she is another game of Thrones
youtuber and she's one of my closest
friends in his community she's one
person whose opinion I respect a lot in
all week long gray area and I have been
analyzing all these different photos
that have been coming out so yesterday
when these ones came out I was went on a
few different
is past her about how I think Arya Stark
ended up with this Valyrian steel blade
since we haven't seen this blade since
season 1 there was a few different ways
I thought Arya could have gotten it in
the strongest auction was that
Littlefinger went back to Ned's office
after he was arrested and he took the
dagger back and he's headed this entire
time although we haven't seen it since
in gray area also believes Littlefinger
has had this dagger the entire time
based off the fact that Littlefinger was
seen with it once again in the books so
I think the showrunners will use that to
explain where it has been all these
years
because I know a lot of people have
wondered if we would ever see this
dagger again especially now that winter
is here and the night King is coming
Westeros needs Valyrian steel now more
than ever now that Arya Stark is in
possession of this dagger this pretty
much confirms what we've been talking
about for months Arya Stark will kill
Littlefinger at the end of season 7 and
take this dagger from him and he may
even have it on him once she puts him
out of his misery but I am a little bit
surprised at HBO would allow her to wear
this blade so blatantly during a photo
shoot usually they're a little bit more
subtle than this could this be some
misdirection to throw us off perhaps but
deep down this only further confirms the
inevitable for me near the end of season
7 Littlefinger will be at Winterfell
and when horrea shows back up
Littlefinger will try to use her and
songs against each other but eventually
they're going to realize what he is
doing in what songs that will finally
sentence Littlefinger to his death then
Arya will be the one to execute him
finally and it's going to be nice to
have the Starks get their hands on some
more Valyrian steel since their own
ancestral family sword was taken from
them and made into two swords for the
Lannisters how ironic would it be if
Arya Stark kills Cersei with the same
Valyrian steel dagger that was used to
try and murder her brother bran which
was orchestrated by a Lannister
that would be one hell of a turn of
events ladies and gentlemen but anyways
comment below and give me your thoughts
on this dagger how do you feel about
Arya Stark now having this blade and how
do you think she got her hands on this
does it confirm Littlefinger's death for
you because it definitely confirms it
for me let me know down below and as
always thanks for stopping by and
watching the video a special thanks to
the supporters of the channel over on
patreon I'll see you all down in the
calm
section bye